thank you very much I'm just gonna tell
you the title of my speech because it's
gonna give you an idea of where we're
going with it and it's long but all
speak quickly it's called beyond
awareness putting the human back in
human trafficking building victim
centric responses that really work good
morning ladies and gentlemen students in
the four years that I've had the immense
honor of working as the United Nations
Office on Drugs and Crime Goodwill
Ambassador to combat human trafficking
so much has happened to this movement
and I have learned so much I've had the
incredible opportunity to travel the
world liaison between governments and
NGOs and survivors networks as part of
the UN's blueheart awareness campaign
I've interviewed scores of people whose
lives have intersected with the
modern-day slave trade which as you know
is worth thirty two billion dollars a
year to those criminals that deal in it
either interviewing those fighting it
those victims victimized by it or those
perpetrating it I actually conducted an
almost four hour interview with a
Spanish sex trafficker which was quite
the experience I have seen us progress
from a point where just a few years ago
a BBC televised debate anchor questioned
the very existence of human trafficking
as though it was something like the
conspiracy theory that the moon doesn't
actually we didn't have a moon landing -
one in which most countries in the world
have acknowledged the severity of the
crimes under this umbrella turn and have
begun legislating to fight them I have
seen a US Congress that is usually so so
hard pressed to come to terms on most
topics agree bipartisanly that we must
fight modern-day slavery as a whole but
given all that progress we are very very
far from making a real meaningful dent
in the problem statistically the latest
UN gift report shows that the conviction
rates for this heinous blight slavery
compared to the rarest of crimes like
homicides in Iceland or kidnapping in
Norway when our US State Department
ambassador my good and learned friend
Luis CdeBaca tells us that there are an
estimated 27 million people living in
slavery at any given time yet the
convictions worldwide do not exceed
4,500 traffickers to this state
something is very very wrong at this
point in time a person living in slavery
has a 1 in 100 chance of ever being
discovered and rescued 1% and the global
percentage of child victims reported
rose from 20% in 2003 to 2006 to 27%
between 2007 to 10 another very
disturbing trend is that in what are
ostensibly law enforcement efforts to
help victims and survivors of both labor
and sexual trafficking which in this
country go about 50/50 more harm is done
post discovery more harm is done to
those emerging from the trauma of
trafficking there is a very real
conflation occurring across the world of
the crime done and its victims instead
of survivors being treated as crime
victims they are often treated as
perpetrators even though the UN and
federal laws to note that those who have
been trafficked are not responsible for
crimes that their traffickers are
committed nor in which they had been
compelled to be involved by the
traffickers the victims are rarely given
something that the UN global plan of
action on tip urges every government to
implement a 30-day minimum period of
reflection in which the suspected
victims of human trafficking have a
decompression period rape victims
interviewed by men and then accused of
lying when they later come forward with
the details of their attack because
they'd been too upset in the first place
to relive the horrific fresh in their
psyche experience in front of someone
that intimidated them we hear that their
interviews are repeated multiple times
by different individuals from different
agencies on different days compounding
that psychological trauma and that often
they are put into detention like living
situations pretrial sometimes for years
on end sometimes for up to two years do
in some cases to a fear that the
witnesses will run away or repatriate if
they
our international victims they are not
treated with the human rights due them
as victims of crimes and this shameful
treatment must end
I also cry a little bit foul that the
survivors of human trafficking are not
called more frequently to the table when
this sort of ideation is occurring I
hope we have some survivors in the
audience we have anybody here hey Holly
I'm really glad that you're here I kind
of wish you were up here with me but
next time with all due respect their
presence would have been most beneficial
for all of us to hear as voices for
change which could have expressed
exactly what is necessary for them
learned through experience and a
vigorous and learned political advocacy
such as that expressed by members of the
National survivors Network it really
shouldn't be Outsiders looking in
deciding what's best for people to whom
this has been done it should be the
people who have lived through this who
could tell you what happened why it
happened what they need now look what we
really want to do is make sure that we
are not just a-- moding together in some
rallying cry against what looks to be a
clear-cut evil slavery but then not
actually pursuing the very specific
courses of action that will impede the
growth of this horrific exploitation of
human beings we've written the initial
wave of finding purpose a common evil to
fight this slavery this new incarnation
this new illicit incarnation of the
slavery we thought had been stamped out
by President Lincoln but now we must
grow from what we've learned and we have
to hunker down to the nitty-gritty
we cannot be hypocrites we can't be
halfway abolitionists who like the
feeling of being on the right side of a
cause but who aren't willing to go the
whole distance down to the ground where
recommendations or policies or laws or
funding are or are not being put into
practice or use it may not even be
intentional just a sin of omission
members of the Madrid ministry of
equality who had put a law necessitating
that period of reflection that I spoke
about on the books for any suspected
victim of human trafficking were
absolutely shocked when I informed them
after researching with local NGOs who
worked with trafficking survivors but
not once since the period in which the
law had been
put into into the books had that period
been granted to one one suspected
survivor this even when a very well
publicized case of a Nigerian pregnant
woman vouched for as a trafficking
victim by various NGOs and the local UN
office was deported immediately back to
Nigeria without the period without a
full investigation into her situation by
the immigration authorities there her
whereabouts are now unknown they just
assumed that writing the law and passing
it was all that was needed and that it
would automatically work as I said I
don't think there was any ill intent to
this it's just they did their part they
wrote the law they passed it and then
their job they felt was finished saying
it does not make it so just ask the
world's major chocolate manufacturers
who swore a pact that they would root
out child slave labor and there Cote
d'Ivoire over 10 years ago lo and behold
an estimated 200,000 children are still
being paid nothing work day and night
using machetes under extremely dangerous
conditions many against their will only
buy a new naming and shaming action
where a handful of them convinced to
agree to new independent outside
audience outside auditing and now plan
to create packages of training and
capacity building with the blessing of
the local government which is always
incredibly important investing in
sustainability as the poor farmers who
produce the raw material become more
successful the idea is they can reinvest
profits to employ others instead of
using child slaves many of whom have
never tasted nor do not even know what
chocolate is and we at point of sale
were blithely buying our M&Ms and our
twixes and our Nutella all those years
thinking just because the problem had
been acknowledged it had been solved now
why I asked would it be impossible or
unlikely for all labels to have a labor
rating on them just as all foodstuffs
have nutritional information on them bad
for business
not so according to a recent Harvard
study that showed that sales actually
rose by 20 percent on items labeled
simply made with good labor practice is
not perfect made just with good labor
practices of course paying fair wages to
people as opposed to forcing labor in
intolerable conditions might cost more
initially
but eh so what we can't endorse the
maximum profit at any cost business
model period we just can't do it as a
race of animals on this planet it's not
possible and be in today's markets those
complying with real zero tolerance I
believe would have a competitive edge
with the ethical consumer isn't knowing
that what we buy even those objects at
those tauntingly low prices knowing that
it was not forged by slave hands as
important as the cotton content or
whether something is organic or its
emissions ratings or its calorie content
President Obama made a great first step
with suggested executive order of last
fall to create a mandatory zero tau 0
slavery tongs for all government
contractors now it's time to expand that
requirement for all companies doing
business in this country I mean let's
let's put any money where our mouth is
let's put some teeth into this statement
that we're anti slavery let's not permit
people to bring slave goods across our
border as we've had a law for over a
century or almost a century to this
effect but never really enacted it you
know it instead of the voluntary self
etting that the California law passed on
this topic asks for a robust impartial
exterior auditing group must be created
that is ongoing in perpetuity it must
protect human beings from the vile or
impulses toward exploitation that will
always exist when there is money to be
made we must make sure to give equal
weight to sex trafficking and labor
trafficking I have spoken to survivors
who agree among themselves they do not
wish one to be labelled more heinous
more worthy of fighting when news
stories purport that sex trafficking is
worse than labor it creates an awkward
dynamic among the survivors they don't
want one to be played more heavily
neither from a treatment or an advocacy
perspective they feel the media is doing
a disservice to the movement since the
ratio of victims in this country seems
to be about 50/50 labor and Ceph traffic
sex trafficking why does sex traffic and
get all the noise yes the rape and abuse
of our own children is especially
horrific and as a mother I I have no no
no argument there but are the beatings
time's born out into murder in dort by
labor trafficking victims any less
Grievous any less worthy of our
abolitionism our domestic minors
more important as people than
foreign-born victims know when you have
looked into the eyes of as many
survivors of unbelievably inhumane
treatment as I have you will know that
the evil people are capable of
inflicting on other people know that
evil people are capable of inflicting on
others for the love of money knows ok
I'm not reading this correctly and you
will know that the evil people are
capable of inflicting on others for the
love of money knows many forms and none
is better than the other when human
beings are relegated to what a Spanish
sex trafficker the one I interviewed at
length told me were like this bottle a
thing a woman is a mercantile object to
be traded we don't care about their
feelings we threatened them and their
families and they work by force they
have truly become objects and that's
where that trafficking term seems
apropos that's the that's the
perspective of the criminals that people
are things to be made a profit off of
not human being stuck in the bonds of
peonage or slavery and that's where we
have to awaken all of our sensibilities
a labor trafficking victim was told here
in this country
she was lower than a dog in this country
of PETA here people care about animals
nobody cares about you a domestic and
sex slave finally came to the conclusion
I had nothing to contribute nothing more
to give on this earth than to stay alive
in a door to keep my brother alive
because the trafficker threatened that
he would kill her brother if she ever
tried to escape and so she endured
rather than killing herself which is
really what she wanted to do service
providers reported from a trauma
perspective issues of sex and labor
trafficking victims present in the same
way it is therefore incredibly important
that the treatment plan that NGOs uses
individualized never waited on which
of trafficking victim here she is best
practices have individualized service
plans so that survivors are looking
forward and setting goals and the case
manager sees to it that those goals are
being met so we must all keep this
anti-trafficking movement universally
and equally opposed to all forms of
slavery above all we must make sure that
by what we are endorsing we are not
doing further harm
now I've recently become aware that some
of the solutions that I have been
vigorously advocating may be at current
moment harming the very individuals they
are designed to help and creating
unintended targets out of others as some
of you may know one of my personal
causes outside of the purview of my
UNODC duties has been advocating for
nationwide robust anti trafficking
legislation at the state level i have
partnered with Polaris project at Pat
USA and castel a to name only a few in
my efforts to enlighten members of the
National Conference of State Legislators
the National Association of attorneys
general and the American Bar Association
of the vast gaps that exist between
federal legislation and what the United
Nations recommends is necessary in the
legal fight against modern-day slavery
and state laws on the topic as you may
have heard me say somewhere no state is
whole in its legislative response to
human trafficking meaning it does not
harmonize with federal law completely
and comes up deficient in at least one
and usually several of ten categories
the Polaris Project is laid out as the
benchmarks for what states must write to
best serve victims and survivors and to
end the atmosphere of impunity that the
criminal traffickers so enjoy here and
throughout most of the world I am happy
to say that at this point most states do
have a basic human trafficking law save
I believe Wyoming whose legislators I
have called out on a dare to write some
of their own not just passed what cases
they accidentally find because how can
your police actively seek to fight a
crime your own laws don't recognize as
one how can you be looking to stop
trafficking if you don't really think
it's a crime and they say well the
federal agents can handle our small
number of trafficking cases and federal
courts can do this but what I have
learned is that only 30 percent of
course in cases referred to the federal
level actually end up there so a third
of those discovered by people not
looking for it might get to federal
the other victims in Wyoming you're kind
of crap out of luck many states in the
past year have passed new laws in areas
like asset forfeiture of traffickers
much like that used with drug
traffickers and right to civil redress
for victims very important because often
even if there's not enough evidence in a
he-said she-said testimony led domestic
labor trafficking case to be tried in
one in Criminal Court it may succeed in
civil and the deposition may reopen
criminal possibilities some are writing
laws to post the National Human
Trafficking Resource Center hotline a
24/7 lifeline that took over 20,000
calls last year and has helped more than
3,000 victims become survivors many are
strengthening the criminalization of
trafficking charges to Class A or one
felonies reducing the appeal of
expanding or switching to human
trafficking from drugs for individuals
and gangs who think there'll be less of
a chance of getting caught and severely
punished for selling people not a ground
or rolled chemical or plant substance
currently you know you're a lot less
likely to be arrested or put in jail for
a long period of time if you sell people
instead of marijuana or cocaine which is
insane
these are all great advances to a point
as long as the new statutes are clearly
written and then used and implemented on
the ground in the sense that they were
meant to be used and more on how to
ensure that through vigorous training in
a moment but one of the key pieces of
legislation that I felt and still feel
with a caveat were most important were
the safe harbor laws those currently on
the books in only 11 states but the most
vital I felt to the well-being of
children trafficked into into commercial
sex their intent in their best most
robust form is to decriminalize the
minor in commercial sex and according to
the tip report there are 100 to 300,000
domestic Americans kids bought and sold
for sex at any given moment on the
streets and on the internet to declare
the child slash teen a victim of human
trafficking of the severus form as no
one under the age of 18 according to the
federal government and the UN has the
mens rea the legal physical
psychological and mental capacity to
consent to their own sale for sex as
they are deemed incapable as minors of
even consenting to sex to criminalize
the adult exploiters the pimps and the
John's to a stronger extent that has
previously the case where every year in
every state hundreds if not thousands of
miners and women are arrested for the
crime of prostitution but their sellers
the pimp traffickers and buyers the
John's are almost never charged almost
never I'm getting a big stop sign but
I'm going to continue I'm sorry if you
get a big hook you can pull me off I'm
sorry a survivor described to me how the
police in front of her a teenager being
arrested said to the man who just
committed statutory rape with her go
home to your wife and family we don't
want to ruin your life
and that that's the common theme among
how John's caught in the act have been
treated perpetually by police and the
common person arrested would be the
child or the woman or the transgendered
person or the boy in commercial sex okay
the intent of these laws is to flip the
lens and see the child in the
transaction as the crime victim not the
perpetrator thereby to expunge the
criminal records of the child slash teen
and these can be girls boys transit
introduced there is no one cookie cutter
profile for a victim of underage sexual
trafficking to entitle the child teen to
the services they so desperately need
these including housing food medical
care psychological counseling education
career training the list goes on and on
of what these kids deserve to be able to
rebuild their lives and recover from the
trauma they've endured in an early life
with little or no choices that held
anything positive for them it may
surprise you to know that most states
child welfare services or Health and
Human Resources do not consider a
domestically trafficked youth to be a
victim of extreme abuse and neglect and
therefore do all those state services
unless they were trafficked by a family
member these safe harbor laws were meant
to change all that were to change the
status of the discovered sex traffic hid
from [ __ ] and [ __ ] appellations which
were hurled at the noble and wonderful
survivor activist Holly Smith when the
arresting police officer pulled her off
the street track when she was a teenager
and rescued her
he swore at her the entire drive back to
the police station and left her feeling
suicidal they were meant to end the
cruel game recounted to me by a Virginia
area teen survivor who told me that when
she and others were put on the track by
their pimp the police cruiser would pull
up flip on their lights and tell the
girls to take off their high heels and
run then they would chase them in the
car
sirens blaring laughing their heads off
these laws are meant to give these young
people back their dignity their right to
choose the life they want well I'm very
disturbed to report that some of those
very laws which are meant to help not
only fail to do that actually harm
survivors in 2010 the Illinois safe
children Act was passed their safe
harbor act and although this May Cook
County State's Attorney Anita Alvarez
stated more than ever before we are
focusing our efforts on rescuing women
and children caught up in this crime and
punishing the traffickers traffickers to
the fullest extent of the law and since
2010 her office has convicted 17
individuals of felony human trafficking
however Chicago police reports show men
John's and pimp traffickers are even
less likely to be arrested on
prostitution related charges than they
were in 2005 down 7% meanwhile
prostitution charges are being almost
exclusively levied against sex workers
ninety-seven percent of the twelve
hundred and sixty-six prostitution
related felony convictions in the past
four years many of the miners only three
buyers only three John's have been
charged with the felony
so this attempt to focus on ending the
demand side it's actually escalated the
number of arrests of them those whom we
consider to be the victims and their
charges have been bumped up for
misdemeanors to felonies criminal
records which can and do haunt them for
the rest of their lives
it must be made very clear that the
anti-sex trafficking movement is not an
anti sex worker movement it is a
movement to end the exploitation of
minors for sex work and because of their
age the state does not have the burden
of proving force for up fraud or
coercion it is a movement to end the
keeping of adults and prostitution who
have been forced lied to or coerced the
chains may be invisible the ones you
can't see as chief sends Lee of the
Truckee California task force explained
but in sex trafficking as in labor
trafficking as the head of European
Interpol expressed it if the person
cannot walk away without the fear of
harm to himself or his/her loved ones
its trafficking the last in
tension of laws named safe harbor is to
create an atmosphere of fear and
long-term punishment for the child
victims of adult exploiters those
looking to sell and buy their vulnerable
bodies their point is to end the cycle
the kids are trapped in for the society
that probably at some point turned its
back on them to give them a second
chance replacing homelessness with
shelter abuse with care judgment with
concern rape with healing a dead end
with a future rife with possibility we
have been trying to change the lens by
which society and law enforcement sees
these young people and by extension the
adults in that profession many of whom
were brought in as minors in the same
trafficking way I have met many brave
and heroic and altruistic survivors of
sex trafficking I admire them to the
skies the youngest was seven she was
seven years old okay she's been put to
work in a Cancun brothel from the age of
four to a few months before I met her
doing things she didn't even know the
words for besides incorrect dos thanks
to an amazing aftercare group home for
child victims she now does addition and
subtraction and loves taking dance
lessons in Pattaya Thailand a notorious
stomping ground for pedophile sex
tourists I met a little boy with the
most beautiful smiling face who held my
hand and invited me to join in Buddhist
evening prayer after showing me around
the self-sustaining mushroom in pig farm
and the clean bright school he attended
at the child protection and Development
Center whose founder told me many of his
old friends on the street were killed
after having been used by pedophiles to
leave no witnesses after leaving the
life when an American girl had put
herself through college with honors only
to be told at the end of a several
interview process at a major corporation
that she could never be hired because of
the prostitution conviction on her
record the last thing we want these laws
to say to them and to kids in their
former positions is that they are bad in
need of punishment we want to let them
know that they have been crime victims
and we intend to help them to our
fullest capacity that law enforcement
should not be their enemy which sadly
sometimes seems to be the case more
often than not but their helpers how is
this going to happen how do we undo this
misinterpretation of law when put into
action I feel it all hinges on clarity
of definition training and political
will the legal language must be super
specific so as not to be twisted and
misinterpreted many of the sex workers
arrested in the Cook County fell in Cook
County fell into a legalistic linguistic
gray area and the recent california
passage of prop 35 has made the
definition of trafficking offenses
Haizi er so they are hard to prove
easier for defense attorneys to wriggle
wriggle their trafficker clients out of
training of law enforcement the
prosecutorial judiciary and defense arms
of the court system as well as that of
social workers and people in the foster
care system is absolutely of the essence
if we are to see a sea change in the way
this crime is prosecuted as victims
recognized as such exonerated and
uplifted this is not about Vice squads
doing sweeps and arrest quotas being met
this is about serious criminals the
traffickers of children and unwilling
adults having strong evidence led cases
built against them and their victims
being identified by an educated law
enforcement that treats them with
dignity respect and sensitivity to the
trauma that they have been through it is
about the legislation being put to its
intended use in the courtroom to end
impunity for traffickers punishing and
deterring them while awarding victims
everything they're due to rebuild their
lives it is also about funding both
federal and state being put into those
services that are being promised and the
programs must be voluntary we cannot
take a crime victim off the street and
incarcerate him or her saying in essence
we have to lock you up for young good
and if you cooperate we'll see what we
can do about your criminal record
because that's kind of how it's working
right now even though some may feel that
they're protecting the victims from
being retracted we don't lock up any
other kind of crime victim we cannot
build trust and lives by acting as
jailers for this reason better safe
harbor laws like one being prepared in
California currently mandate that minors
brought in as trafficking victims not be
put into juvenile delinquency court but
juvenile dependency court the
relationship must be a voluntary
partnership not one the victims are told
as mandatory all of this means an
enormous amount of capacity building as
local NGO leaders survivor visionary
tina front can tell you building a group
home that caters to the specific needs
of sexually trafficked youth is almost
prohibitively expensive our government
and private sister sector must join
hands in this effort to put money where
their mouths are we need to build the
responses these victims need and we
betray them by not doing so they do not
do well in group homes with other youths
who have not undergone similar
experiences and are quick to that judge
and shame that public-private funding
has to be put into the services for
victims but not taken mainly from
traffickers assets or John's penalties
which must go directly to the victims
themselves to be it to start their new
lives that funding also has to be
allocated for that education and
training
all those in law enforcement and the
court system I mentioned before we must
have a universality a common knowledge a
common goals
fueled by experience and driven to
specific goals in informed
anti-trafficking not a hazy witch-hunt
that felon eyes does anything to do with
sex industry or immigration offenses
that training must extend beyond those
fine men and women responsible for our
law and order first responders medical
personnel all those in education and
janitorial professions in institutional
licensing and in the travel and
hospitality industry are absolutely
crucial for any national battle of human
trafficking to work for the victims are
unseen and their traffickers like to
keep it that way it may be that they are
generally confined to one place or they
they are moved around all the time to
avoid detection
they are intimidated and told not to
interact with others to lie of question
and to fear authorities when they
surface it takes a trained eye to use
the moments of contact with the outside
world out of the grasp of their
traffickers as a ticket out of hell
all too often trafficking victims have
that one chance where they could be
identified and rescued but it is missed
last week I was honored to be trusted to
hear the story of two brave labor
trafficking survivors from the
Philippines their tale exemplifies the
challenges we still faced fighting this
crime while testifying to their
extraordinary courage in it there are
several points in which we see missed
opportunities for the prevention their
exploitation by authorities or their
identification as victims which could
have led to an earlier rescue by others
but at the end of the day their own
fortitude brought them their freedom
alright and the weird thing about this
and this is my last big part of what I'm
gonna say is not this very point but I
almost thought that the facility in
which they've worked was where my
father's mother spent her last days it
was an assisted living facility in Long
Beach and it may very well have been the
one in which my husband's grandmother
lived all right let's call them Amy and
Jonah in the Philippines they did not
know each other but they were recruited
by the same woman one year apart Amy had
a relative who worked for her in the US
Jonah had worked on construction
projects for her in the Philippines both
were asked very nicely if they wanted to
come work for her in the US they didn't
question what kind of work amy said
getting an offer to come to america was
like getting the winning lottery ticket
the woman told them she had done this
many times before that getting them work
visas would go very smoothly she would
handle it all she had them study with a
Taekwondo master for a little over a
month then leave the country in return
with the type
no group that they were all given black
belts and then all of them applied for
athletes visas at the US Embassy where
there were no questions they hadn't been
prepared to answer no visible suspicions
about them Jonah was absolutely
overjoyed flying into LAX he was so
excited and no one at the border stopped
them or suspected the trafficking of
this group of happy martial artists once
in this country the woman asked for the
passport so she could keep them safer
for them and Jonah complied she brought
them to an assisted living facility in
Long Beach California one of two that
she owned and ran there for a week Jonah
apprenticed with AMI in how to take care
of the elderly patients that boarded
their neither of them had any training
and practical nursing or medical care at
all but he was not prepared for such
work and he became physically ill when
made to change bedpans and and and do
things that he just that they weren't in
his range of experience and he found it
very very difficult ami had already been
there for over a year stuck she had been
told shortly after arrival that she owed
the woman $12,000 u.s. she would be paid
$600 a month but 300 would be held back
to pay off her debt and she must work
for the woman for ten years to repay her
she was threatened with disavowal and
deportation if she ever tried to leave
told not to welcome the streets because
the police would pick her up and made to
work for six months in a row without a
single day off Amy and Jonah the latter
who spoke almost no English when he
arrived became each other's only allies
they were made to sleep on the floors
next to the elderly clients beds or
wherever they could find purchase in the
common areas they were berated for
steaming up the bathroom by taking
showers at first they were allowed to
eat the leftovers of food that they
prepared for the clients
but then she complained she was spending
too much money on food so their Asians
were cut and sometimes they were
compelled to eat rotted food because
apparently it is against labour laws to
work 24 hours a day Amy had to falsify
work logs claiming that all the woman's
extended family worked hours at the
facility but in reality it was herself
and Jonah doing everything amazingly
several times Ombudsman from the various
licensing agencies that certified the
facilities came always found them on
duty and questioned why they never had
any time off but were only concerned
really with the number of elderly
clients housing the facility
not the obvious labor infractions
occurring eventually a neighbor who had
been watching the pair work non-stop
texted Amy that if she ever needed any
help
then one day she received a text from a
woman in the FBI the neighbor had
alerted that she met with the agent who
got Amy to agree to wear a wire Amy went
to the facility and was able to make the
women pour out all the details of the
debt she said she owed her all the
incriminating evidence that would help
prove her crime then she stayed
courageously after wearing a wire
continued to wear a while for a week
while Jonah ran away the FBI had him
call the woman and extract similar
information over the phone the woman
called the police and accused him
falsely of stealing jewelry which she
had hidden but Amy found and called his
family at home shaming him and them
trying to get them to reveal his
whereabouts or send him back to her when
he did call her she reiterated that they
both owed her and that they would have
to work for her even after the ten years
were over because she was the one who
brought them over and therefore they
were essentially in her debt for
perpetuity at this point he told her he
wasn't coming back to work for her but
that he would find money somehow and
would get it to her whereupon she got
agitated and said she needed it soon and
hurled insults at him Jonah had been
placed by the FBI in the Salvation Army
shelter he felt very alone and
intimidated thereby the hostility of the
other homeless there who couldn't
understand why he was allowed to remain
there during the day he had worked since
he was a teenager and never thought his
life would come to this currently there
are almost no housing options geared for
male trafficking victims and men are
much more unlikely to come forward and
ask for help now their story has a happy
ending
the woman was eventually convicted to a
prison a prison sentence al biet not
long enough but she would never be able
to run an institution again they were
awarded restitution in court and felt
satisfied when the judge attacked the
woman's character for treating them the
way that they she had they got T visas
and special recommendations for
expedited green cards since they
cooperated with a successfully completed
case against their trafficker and now
are happily employed and members of the
National survivors network fomenting
change for others all with an incredible
sense of humor these are very very funny
joyful people but we see so many points
in this story where this could have been
avoided in their home country the
recruiter the woman and the transporter
the Taekwondo master had been doing this
for years and the authorities had never
caught on the embassy smelled nothing
awry nor did the Border Patrol at LAX
nor the assisted living licensing
spectres nor the families of the elderly
clients who clearly knew these two
worked around the clock all these were
areas in which if the proper anti
trafficking education had been the
by those in charge these friends
wouldn't lost one or two years of their
lives to indentured servitude to
understand the entire picture on top of
the intimidation at being in a strange
culture in an ardent wish to support
their parents back home their Asian
culture of filial piety duty and respect
that molded them into ideal victims for
this evil woman must be understood and
to some extent anticipated when
searching for potential victims out
there another domestic labor trafficking
survivor from Indonesia told us how she
wrote her trafficker an apology note
detailing all the ways she had failed
her abuser and made her mad before
running away with the help of a neighbor
and the FBI she asked me to mention the
importance of extending the statute of
limitations for trafficking charges to
be brought because of the time needed to
come to the right mindset for a survivor
to be able to prosecute we may be
missing the possibility that those among
us are traffic because not only is our
country not rife with the same level of
economic desperation some source
countries are but the American culture
is so individualistic and rebellious it
is harder for us to understand being
bound by inherited or instilled debt and
never underestimate the holding power of
trying to be a good person
that the traffickers exploit in both
cases above the victims stayed longer
out of not wanting to do harm to those
in their care Amy and Joan are worried
about what would happen to the elder
elderly people that they truly loved and
the latter survivor about the small
children she looked after and would miss
in effect slave labor can be found
everywhere under almost every rock you
can turn over even in the most
unexpectedly innocuous seeming sub
settings in California right now a big
case is breaking involving many men
traffic to work on Christmas tree farms
their lives threatened if they tried to
leave and lastly if we've come so far in
our understanding in action on human
trafficking how is it that the TVPA are
a still awaits free passage at the
federal level this crucial federal
legislation is what state legislations
wish they were and yet it teeters on an
uncertain brink because reap artists
because partisan politics have stalled
its reap acid its latest iteration
incorporates elements from a bill that
Senator Ron Wyden introduced and that I
advocated for in the past and it would
provide funding for those grant programs
for states to assist victims of child
traffic in creating pilot areas for that
capacity-building that is so urgently
needed in relation to this
assisted-living labor trafficking case
it would strengthen the ability to
prosecute those who fraudulently recruit
individuals in foreign labor
and helps foreign governments
investigate labor recruitment centers or
trafficking victims may be recruited the
number one priority expressed by Jonah
senators Patrick Lee Lee Leahy and Marco
Rubio continued to be staunch supporters
of the TPP our a and in honor of human
trafficking Awareness Month
they both publicly committed to passing
this bill this year the Senate and House
of Representatives must follow their
leadership come together and get this
done there's simply no excuse to put off
the passage of this legislation any
longer we cannot let this major piece of
our armamentarium against the purveyors
of human beings slip away but the great
news is that we have now have all of
this experience to learn from some
successes to build on and an
increasingly strong and vocal network of
survivors to lead our path let's
redouble our efforts in earnest now in a
sophisticated dedicated earnest
partnership eradicating slavery from the
face of the earth thank you